so this this thing that we were just
showing you guys is really it's straight
out of this crazy Robyn D'Angelo book
white fragility it precedes that by a
lot actually I have a I found an essay
that I wrote from 1991 in which I'm
pointing out the pitting of modernity
versus post modernity which I'll
actually share a couple of tips from
well later so you know to those who say
you guys helped create this beast no no
we didn't we're not we're not copping to
that just no but you know James Lindsey
Peter Berg osha and helen pluck rose as
the people who put together that
grievance studies expose i guess they
don't want to call it a hoax this
precedes D'Angelo but it's the current
bible of the moment so in the last
episode i attempted to steal man may be
her most irritating point right the idea
that all white people are racist and i
said well if you if you understand that
she's redefining what racist means and
now what racist means in her world is
that you are accruing benefits from an
historical system of racism inequality
then it's true
yes if you have white skin you continue
to accrue the benefits from an
historical system of racism and quality
that is true but redefining the key word
and the sentiment is cheating here are
some other things that happen in the
book that you know i hope i hope you
don't have to read it but if you do
she conflate systemic problems and this
is to that to that redefinition of the
word racism she conflate systemic
problems with individual ones while
claiming to be very clear on the
differences so it's kind of a it's a
bait and switch with regard to the
system is rigged and therefore you were
racist well no you can't you can't do
that individuals and populations are
different she also conflates a
biological understanding of humanity
which is part of what we are trying to
share with the world with social
Darwinism so social Darwinism as a
phrase in which both are capitalized is
a long debunked bastardization of
Darwinism which has nothing really to do
with an actual evolutionary
understanding of the world
but this bastardization known as social
Darwinism suggests that currents
social conditions are inevitable and
good you know it's an excuse for why the
rich are rich the rich are rich because
Darwin said so because nature said so no
that's wrong and that's not how
evolution works but she she makes this
kind of kind of point and thus slotting
scientists like us into this twisted in
archaic belief system she sort of just
leaves that for for her adherence to
come back to she posits among other
things that if we are indeed all equal
which many of us believe us to be the
only explanation for disparities and
condition must be the result of
discrimination and here she's conflating
equal with identical to right equal and
identical to are not the same thing
she rails against the way that Black
History Month is celebrated because she
says it's it reinforces whiteness this
will not be the first time if you're
reading this book that you face a
dilemma
you can't win you're damned if you do
damned if you don't should we then not
celebrate Black History Month
well then violence is silenced violence
but if you do celebrate it in any way at
all apparently then you're doing it
wrong and you're further demonstrating
your your racism silences violence and
saying the wrong thing is violence or
its equivalent therefore your choice is
to repeat after us and the problem is
there's then no basis whatsoever to
object on the because what's being said
is incorrect which almost all of it is
or because the policy proposals that are
being advanced are going to lead to the
destruction of things on which we are
all depending there are lots that mean
and this of course happened to us in
microcosm at Evergreen yep because the
primary among the many objections I
would say the primary objection to what
was being advocated was that it would
destroy the college and that lots of
people including us including our
students including the very people that
they were claiming to be helping we're
depending on the college being
functional and you know driving it into
bankruptcy wasn't going to help anybody
so it's right yeah was there was there
language at Evergreen to say that you
were actually about to [ __ ] the
college and that nothing
that you're talking about could possibly
be accomplished if you do that nope
because the very fact of objecting meant
that they were going to portray it was
racist yes because because the movement
has declared has named itself cleverly
and this is not the first time we've
seen this there are many examples of
movements like this an tyfa is one
frankly pro-life is one but anti-racist
no actually not you know I I'm here to
say I'm anti anti racism that does not
make me racist no because the movement
is named in a way that is that is
designed to trap you and if so to go
back to the to the book specifically for
just a couple of moments
if you don't view race as the single
most defining feature of the human
experience the single most defining
feature of the human experience you are
according to the book white fragility
both racist and in denial used to be of
course that viewing everything through
racial lens was what made you a racist
well times change don't they so this
book is a hot mess of sloppy scholarship
and cherry-picked data but that's not
actually its biggest flaw let me just
quote DeAngelo herself here a couple
times from the book she says she says I
have been unable to hide my surprise
that the black man is the school
principal of all white people she writes
I realized that we see ourselves as
entitled to and deserving of more than
people of color deserve wow she's right
about one thing she's racist
like Robert D'Angelo's actually racist
and it seems that it's possible that
it's her personal racism that has
projected all the rest of white America
at the moment that's given jet fuel to
riots that started as protests that were
good faith and had a germ of necessity
at the at the core of them that we now
have a totally chaotic and undefensible
movement so if you don't share Robin
D'Angelo's racism as in fact the vast
majority of Americans don't your
defensive nostalgia stirred and
caricatured as many of you who have had
to sit through sit through some of these
workplace trainings will have
experienced that's going to be held up
itself as proof of your racism and your
desire to defend yourself against false
claims being evidence of
white fragility your white supremacism
is in fact it's another rhetorical trick
and it's I think the central Kafka trap
of the entire book urx no I'm not by
denying that your ex you've proven that
your ex classic Kafka trap and that's
the only bit of argumentation in the
book that she actually engages him so I
like this model it makes a lot of sense
to me
here's the question I have so I don't
assume that Robyn D'Angelo is
well-intentioned she's obviously getting
quite wealthy advancing this particular
wrong set of ideas it is possible though
that you know we have argued that people
have better access by orders of
magnitude
to what takes place in their own mind
than they do to the next closest mind to
them right you can see into your own
mind not perfectly there's lots of stuff
that happens in our minds that we can't
see but but we do have some access to
what goes on inside of our own minds so
Robyn D'Angelo looking to her into her
own mind has discovered some completely
preposterous stuff and yes offensive if
you look at it and you know it's I'm not
sure I would say it was racist because
the question is does she want to see it
that way it's clearly prejudiced right
but the point is unable to hide my
surprise that the black man is the
school principal I mean these are just
two but there's it's riddled throughout
the book oh right that that's hurt
speaking so she clearly has this shared
right well here's the point she has
effectively portrayed all she doesn't
know what's going on in other people's
minds yeah so having looked into her own
mind maybe she's just decided you know
her mind is a good model for everybody
else's and it isn't she's put a mirror
up to herself and then declared that she
put a mirror up to society and you she's
trained as a sociologist putting a
mirror to society is what sociology is
supposed to be of course sociology has
long since captured and ridiculous not
everyone there are some excellent
sociologists out there Nicolas course I
wouldn't being one he he you know
sociology suggests
more scientific than it is I would say
she is on the sociopath oh good no it
wasn't expensive so I just thought I'd
try it
I need the cricket audio yeah but but
anyway it does it does seem like she is
projecting and one would imagine that
she knows better than this but even if
she doesn't how tragic is it that we are
going to grind civilization to a halt
over a misunderstanding over whether
what goes on in Robin D'Angelo's mind is
a good match for what goes on and
everybody else's mind and so I don't
know it's it's stunning yeah I will
point out yeah friend of ours on Twitter
may have solved the problem cut the
Gordian knot as it were with respect to
white fragility so somebody had asked
what to do yeah in the case there had
their employer was insisting that they
read white for drill at a chair and Dave
suggested that the answer to this was
I'll read that if you'll read 1984 thank
you
struck me as a very good answer thank
you for your work I am a person of color
working at a religious private school I
just signed up for a book club to read
white fragility with colleagues who are
mostly female white upper-class etc any
advice Wankel up like a lot yeah first
of all your description of the
demographic descriptors of the other
people who are in this book club is is
telling and is typical it does tend to
be pretty much middle-class and
upper-class white women who are
promoting this particular book this
particular screed that is so filled with
hatred and ridiculous thinking and that
you know why that might be is a
conversation not for right now but but
for another time
but you know I would say at one level
you know you play the idiocy of the book
to your advantage in order to get them
to listen to you if if you were the
person of color in the room and you are
listening to us and therefore at least
have some suspicion that the book is not
what it claims and is divisive rather
than unify
if they start disagreeing with you point
out that they they actually have no leg
to stand on on this room because you are
do you are the person who is suffering
rather than rather than them I just
don't see anything dishonourable in
playing their game on them at the point
that they would insist on winning
regardless of whatever else is true I
might come at it slightly differently
but in part we don't know what you mean
by PSC because let's say you're Asian
and we also don't know from blamed sorry
but from your name I can't tell if
you're male or female and so that's
going to be probably probably more
effective if you're female although
frankly a woman pushing back against
other women is going to play very
differently gonna have to use different
strategies than a man pushing back
against a group of women but I would say
if by POC you mean that you're black
then maybe it's a marvelous opportunity
now it's certainly not an opportunity
without risk but imagine for example
that the approach you took was I've read
the book I don't believe it and as
people in the room are trying to insist
that they are racist and are trying to
come to grips with it and that it is the
kind of problem that must be addressed
and can't be addressed and all of the
other contradictions that these people
espouse you might just call them out in
their own interest and they might hear
you
trying to liberate them from this set of
circular idiocy 'he's right if they
heard you saying you know what I hear
you asserting that you're definitely
racist because you're white my
experience that's not how it worked I
mean that's just not the nature of it so
now you begin with a caveat and
basically unfortunately if your lineage
making you a person of color is East
Asian and they this doesn't show up in
white fragility but it's certainly in
the ideology probably what will come
back at you is well Asians are a tool of
white supremacy as well yeah which is a
line that we ran into it evergreen and
you know it's quite common it's it's
absurd and ridiculous and offensive and
all these things but you know you're
your most protected against the idiot
ideology the I guess the target the skin
here is the darkest your skin is this
case it's ridiculous
you don't imagine that if you are black
do not imagine that because you are
black you will be safe I would say it
depends on one of two things
or it depends on one primary thing yeah
is if the people pushing the ideology
are really in the room rather than
people who are a victim of this ideology
that is to say they are being forced
into admitting things that aren't true
if the people who are leading it are
there then you're in for special
punishment because mm-hmm claiming that
you don't see it is going to be viewed
as very damning but he or she has said
book-club so maybe maybe not yeah the
chances are that you're dealing with
basically people who are engaged in
embracing a zombie ideology but the the
people who are selling it aren't there
in which case you might be able to
liberate them
[Music]